je m'appelle marc vernier je suis
candidat aux élections législatives dans
la 2e circonscription des landes
candidat des républicains avec le
soutien du nouveau centre et de lui des
artisans je suis un homme de terrain
c'est bien deux dernières années j'ai
représenté défendu accompagner mes
concitoyens dans le cadre des mandats
consulaires qui m'ont été confiées et
pour lesquelles j'ai étais tu connais
mon territoire ces habitants leurs
difficultés leurs attentes les projets
qu'ils appellent de leurs voeux c'est ma
conception du rôle de député défendre
son territoire et ses habitants c'est la
raison de mon engagement est de ma
candidate